Started.
So today we're really excited to welcome
for laying flat again and released from
being called roommates at Chapel Hill.
They both going on some
very fascinating careers,
so we're going to set a
lot of records for running.
She's running for Olympic Games now.
When you bronze medal in one
and just a few weeks ago,
she wants sex leading the American team.
She holds the record for the 3,100 and
500 meter indoors and pretend name 15 k
mark racists.
It's fascinating to me personally how
long she's been able to stay on top of her
games and so many athletes peak or
only to a single moments works for Nike
running and doing digital marketing.
And after she graduated and then did a
career change and went to culinary school
and having our city.
So what am I looking at this Cup book?
We know that the authors have a
serious chops both and knowing,
running and annoying cooking.
So it's no wonder it made the
New York Times bestseller list.
Please welcome Caroline and Elise
[inaudible].
Thank you so much for
having us here at Google.
It's such an honor to be here for me.
Um,
I always admire Google as a company
and worked in digital marketing at Nike
Promo is 10 years.
And if I hadn't been working at Nike,
I probably would've wanted
to come work at Google.
So it's awesome to be here and see
what an amazing campus you guys have.
And today we've been traveling
all over as part of our book tour.
We've had the chance to go to some awesome
running cities and speak to runners
and athletes of all
levels. And for us, um,
this is an opportunity for us to
spread is such an important message to,
to athletes and what we're teaching
people is that there's more to healthy
eating and just killed,
killed Jews. It's a,
also health food is a juicy burger and
you want to teach people that help who
doesn't have to be planned in boring.
It can be really nourishing and really
flavorful and keep you satisfied so
you're not reaching for junk food. So
I'm going to dive into that. But first,
I know you guys probably want to
hear some stories from Shalane, um,
just since she's just returned
from an incredible race in Rio.
Yeah. So about a couple of weeks
ago, I ran a little race down in Rio.
It was an incredible experience.
It was my fourth,
but I never take it for granted.
Getting to wear a USA across my chest.
There's so much pride and
honor behind that. Um,
and the race itself,
I had high expectations hoping to land
on a podium and wear a nice little
necklace around my neck after the race.
But that didn't happen. I play six,
but we had the highest finish for
an American team ever. We went six,
seventh and nine, which was
huge. We have the definitely,
I'm a tough challenge. You East
can seem to dominate the distances.
So it was quite an
accomplishment for us. Um, uh,
but I did have to overcome a lot of
fear actually for this last race of my
Olympic trials, qualifier for the
marathon was in la and it was funny.
Have you run in the heat eat
before he can pretty taxing
and arduous. And so I never
run a heat Marin on, um,
suffer in la at the Olympic trials.
And that's obviously I'm kind of a tough,
tough race because you're trying to make
the Olympic team and you have to finish
top three. And I ended up, um,
having a really hard race in the
final three miles. I barely finished,
but I hung on for third.
And so I created a lot of fear at first
time I'd ever had to receive an IMV
after the race. And it kind of scarred
me that experience running and such, um,
uh,
deprive dehydration state.
And you would think at this level I would
know everything. But really I don't.
And um, so I have a lot of fear
going into Rio cause again,
it was going to be a hot and humid race.
So I had to over come a lot of
fear going into that. And, um,
I reached out to a lot of resources
to overcome that fear and, uh, uh,
hydration plan. I relied on my best
friend to help me come up with that.
And then a lot of, um,
research. I went to, um, uh,
Olympic training center and did an,
a hydration analysis.
And then apparently I'm a, they
classified me as an aggressive sweater,
so I had to probably drink three times
more than the rest of the athletes out
there, but I was able to do that
and have a successful marathon. Um,
but beyond that, um, you know,
talking about fear, I'm Alisa and I,
um,
completely made career changes a little
bit and collaborated on this beautiful
cookbook.
Then three years ago,
the idea started just at my kitchen
table while we're eating a delicious meal
and at least it made some career changes.
And I was trying to meet the goal
to make it before the Olympic team.
And we came up basically over this meal,
the idea of writing a cookbook and sharing
the knowledge that she gained and how
I felt kind of deprived and just,
um,
a burden with my own diet as an athlete.
And I wanted to make sure that
I was feeling properly. And,
um, so that's how it began at least this
year. A little bit more of the story.
It's some things. And so it's been such
an honor for me to write this cookbook,
so we've known each
other for for 16 years.
So to get to write a cookbook together
has been a lot of fun with it.
We were college roommates and teammates.
Um,
and then we both have a chance to move
west after graduating from UNC, um,
and then working for Nike
in different capacities.
So I worked in a cubicle wall Shalane
Wayne's down below on the fields running
laps and I always would look out my
window and wish I was down there on the
field too. Um, and anyways,
um, the cookbook came to be,
we hadn't seen each other in a
couple of years and I had been,
I had the chance during my career,
my career in marketing to work abroad.
Um, I worked in Geneva, Switzerland, um,
for not to be named video game company.
And during that time I got really inspired
by the food culture in Switzerland.
My Diet changed drastically when
we moved over there from, um,
and I can suffer it in college.
I suffered from a lot of injuries and I
thought it was a healthy leader and what
I had been eating in college that led
to the stress fractures and led to me
suffering from, um, athletic game area.
It went away as soon as I moved to
Switzerland and changing my diet,
my diet changed for meeting white meat,
chicken breasts,
a whole roasted chicken and from Veggie
burgers to grass fed ground beef and
from processed fake butter
spreads to real butter.
And all these decadent foods that we
had learned to label in our country as
unhealthy actually made me healthier and
happier and stronger than ever before.
And so I had this realization that I had
been depriving myself and these amazing
foods that not only
tasted it tasted great,
but we're also helping my body absorb
vitamins and nutrients so much better than
what I had been eating, running at a
high level in college. Um, and I decided,
decided that I wanted to feel to inspire
other athletes of all levels. And so I,
um,
we moved back to the u s and I went to
study culinary nutrition at a top school
in New York City. And after that, uh,
wasn't really sure what I was going to
do and how I would get my message out to
athletes, um, but had the chance to
have dinner together and we reunited.
We hadn't seen each other.
Um,
so that night we were talking and sharing
stories from college and catching up
on good times.
Um,
but sooner conversation got more serious
and we talked about how many athletes
we had seen suffer at every
level from our own teammates. Um,
in college too.
A lot of young female athletes I'm
suffering due to eating mostly a processed
foods,
diets and calorie counting calories
and feeling like they had to follow the
prescription way of eating instead of,
and seeing food just as fuel instead of
seeing it as indulgent nourishment. Um,
and so that night I said to, um, showing,
she told me how she always felt while
she was marathon training, drained and,
and hangry, and she just felt depleted
all the time. And I told her that night,
maybe you just need more
better in your life too.
So we quickly started revamping her diet
and we thought maybe we should write a
cookbook together some day so we can
get this message out to thousands of
runners across the country
and athletes. And, um,
I never actually thought we would get
our courage up to write the book, but,
but a whole,
a whole year went by with a lot of text
messages back and forth and more dinners
together.
And finally I took my daughter
being born for me to realize like,
this is what I need to do.
And I quit all,
put all my other projects to write our
book proposal fulltime and just went for
it. And I tried to channel
channel shall lanes, uh,
energy and competitive edge as must,
as much as possible.
And I poured everything
into our book proposal.
We sent it out not knowing if anyone
would ever want to publish our book.
And we said, well, if nobody
wants to publish it, we'll
publish it ourselves. Um,
so we sent it out to publishers and we
ended up with eight bids for our books.
So we got to pick our first
choice publisher, which was, um,
Rodale and they've been,
they've done an job of making
them beautiful buck that
we hadn't envisioned and
sticking to our nutrition
philosophy, which is, um,
we came to call it indulgent nourishment
and indulgent Martin nourishment. Um,
we want to prove to people
that healthy food can be cool.
It doesn't have to be land and you can
eat these amazing foods and hot and use
local seasonal ingredients and top
it with olive oil and olive oil based
dressing or a buttery sauce.
And by eating this way,
eating these real foods and fueling
yourself, um, you ended, you're not,
you don't have the cravings anymore for
the job getting the bars and the package
package foods. Um, so we, uh,
are proud to have the first cookbook
for runners that doesn't have calorie
counts or nutrition facts.
And instead we're teaching people to
get back in tune with listening to their
bodies needs. And, um,
we've been beyond excited
to buy the amount of media.
The media has been really excited about
what gets appeared in runner's world and
then women's running magazine and
outside magazine and food and wine.
And we were just a couple of weeks ago
in New York City to be on good morning
America.
And Best of all,
like we had this really high goal that
people told us we would never achieve,
which was to make the New York
Times bestseller list and right.
That's the best, right? We're
going to shoot them the best. Uh,
Shlain is competitive and I channel
porter called heart and soul
into this book and we want, um,
not only to inspire people
to get into the kitchen,
but to inspire people to seek out the
best ingredients that are body to buy
local, seasonal food. Um, it's not only
better for the planet and better for you,
it just is more nutrient dense.
So it will leave you feeling satisfied
and more energized and not reaching for a
sugar fix and not reaching
for a coffee fix all day,
which I noticed you guys
have plenty of opportunities.
Not the coffee's bad.
Um,
and as part of that,
um,
we've been trying to show people
improve that dieting doesn't work.
Um,
a lot of people in our country or Yoyo
dieting and every year it's a different
kind of diet, whether that's, um,
a paleo diet or a low fat diet or juicing
or any of these extreme diets in the
end. And the science is there now and we
go into it in the book, but diets just,
they're no fun. They caused your
body to have, um, metabolism swings.
And in the end,
a lot of people try these diets and
they don't work and they end up gaining
weight. And instead when you
get to eat real food and um,
take the time to get into the kitchen and
cook, you'll feel so much better than,
than ever before.
And one of the things that you tell that's
kind of our most important message is
the single greatest thing you can do as
an athlete to improve your performance
and your health and is happiness,
is to learn to cook.
And Pete was just showing with us how you
guys have a kitchen here where you can
learn to cook,
which is amazing.
So I highly recommend that you take
advantage of the cooking classes here.
Um, people often tell us like, I
don't have time to cook, right?
Have a full time job and I'm training
and I have kids and it Shalane can get
out, go in the kitchen and cook after a
20 mile training run at high altitude and
made homemade sauce and homemade
meatballs in a hurry. Green Salad.
Then I think the rest of us can
to a lot of people think, well,
she must have a private chef with Navarra.
I'm going to hire you.
She's not only cooking for herself,
but often going to the training camps
and cooking for all of her teammates too.
Um,
so it's pretty impressive to see that.
I'm a let her talk about some of her
favorite recipes in the book here in a
second. But I'm the other, the other
thing I wanted to share about, um,
the good fats.
So we'd really,
all of our recipes are full of flavor
and the reason they're so flavorful is
because they're so rich in good,
healthy fats.
And there's been kind of ingrained in
our culture over the years since when we
were in high school and college that
fat is bad for you in fat causes heart
conditions in fact causes weight gain
when in fact the opposite is true.
Fact Prevents Weight Gain Fat,
helps regulate your metabolism,
it helps you feel energized.
It's a great source of energy.
Runners get so focused on protein,
protein, protein, and carbo loading.
And really fat is a
great source of energy.
It helps when you're eating a
salad or veggies or something, um,
hurting and helping you
put fat on top of it.
It helps your body absorb all the
vitamins and nutrients better.
Many vitamins are fat soluble,
so you can't get the most out of what the
foods you're eating without having the
fat in your diet. And
especially for Google and, um,
employees that is so
important for brain health.
So it keeps you smarter and
prevents, um, depression.
So anyone who works here probably had
a mom that was cooking good meals with
healthy fats as a kid because
that's how you guys got here. Yeah,
it was good for your brain health.
I have a toddler goes to Europe,
two years old and she eats is
it, this is incredible, uh,
way of eating and I know like it's
really good for her brain development.
So especially for kids where
their brains are developing,
they need the good fats in their diet.
And that's,
we talk about butter because we love
butter, but it's not just butter. You,
you have a range of fats,
you have coconut oil and olive oil and
even fat from really good quality meat
sources. So grass fed, ground beef and
aids. And for us, we prefer dark meat,
chicken over white meat
chicken because it's more,
it's got more of the good nourishing
fats in there and also more vitamins and
minerals. So, um, there's lots of
sources of great health and fats.
The ones you want to avoid are the ones,
the cheap oils that are in
packaged foods. And, um,
there's a lot of packaged foods out there.
Um,
when I'd see actually people think chips
and cookies, but there's so much more.
It's also that the dressings
and the sauces and all the
quick fixes that we have
in our grocery store to get
dinner on the table faster.
But in our book we teach people how to
make dressings from scratch and sauces
and Pesto and calmness. And when
you're making these foods from scratch,
you're able to use to really good oils.
Whereas if you're buying
Hamas in the grocery store,
which sounds like a healthy food,
it's often made with cheap
oils and preservatives, which
are great for your body.
Um,
so we really want to inspire people to
get into the kitchen and put on an apron
and make it, have fun with
cooking. Um, make it, uh,
activities you do on a Sunday afternoon
to prepare meals for the week and a half
stuff prepared in advance.
Um,
so I'm going to let Shalane share talk
about some of her favorite recipes and how
the one paid, right? That's gain
celebrity status. Um, I guess you can,
if we were to measure a celebrity says
through Instagram, at least one tool.
But um,
so these are our superhero and
muffins and as you can see,
they look delicious and you can make
him with chocolate chips or not.
I spread the chocolate chips.
Um, so these are great. Really.
See she didn't cause they have some
good butter in it and they also are made
with almond flour, which is a little bit
different than your traditional flower.
Um,
so the very satiating.
They stick in my stomach and I feel
like I don't get hungry or hours,
which is great because I don't want
to be running around high ingredients,
at least describes it. Um, so
I'll hobbies for breakfast,
I will have them as a snack.
I'll have him for dessert.
They're stable and people are
cooking these up like crazy.
They're definitely different because
we're tricking people. They taste awesome,
but they've got a Zucchini
and carrots in it too. So, um,
these are for what we
classify as a long Sunday run.
These muffins were designed
for superheroes like you.
They're packed full of veggies in Sweden
with maple syrup instead of refined
sugar. In addition, almond
meal and whole grain oats,
replacing nutrient strict white
flour user, my goto muffins,
nourishing and sweetly satisfying for an
easy grab and run breakfast and do not
fear the butter.
You only got one with healthy fats
is a great way to start your day.
That helps transport important vitamins
throughout your hardworking body will
help keep you satisfied
longer. Um, so yeah,
I recommend these. These are
huge hit for kids, for husbands,
wives, um, for parties.
They're just are nice.
Do you want to talk about some
of the other foods that you love?
Training Therea Burrito?
Um, yeah. Let's see. So I
pretty much primarily, you know,
a lot of them say once you create this
cookbook and you've already tested all of
these recipes and numerous
signs of eating all of them,
it feels like a hundred times each.
But I genuinely don't
stray from the cookbook.
I feel like I can rely on this because
they know every ingredient is going to
have is power pack.
I everything I'm putting in my body,
it has a purpose and I like knowing
that and I can control that. Um,
I always say in athletics you control
what you can control cause there's a lot
of variables that you can't control.
So I try to control what
I'm putting in for fuel. Um,
I'd say another favorite food, um, is
our high altitude vice and meatballs.
These are also a huge fan.
I had 10 teammates go to the Olympics
this summer in Reno and I made these up
probably once a week
for them. Um, and bison,
we eat quite a bit of bison
because it's really rich in iron,
which is really important for endurance
athletes because burn an endurance
athlete, especially if I
train at high altitude, um,
I need the red blood cell
production and it gives me energy.
It transports the oxygen.
Uh,
so there's thought and stories
behind each one of these recipes.
And on top of being healthy
for me, they're delicious.
Like I created them. So,
um, I think in the past I used to just
eat super bland and boring and I wasn't
excited to eat my food and I
just felt like this burden,
like I was describing
and counting calories and
worrying about getting to this
race weight,
which is optimal for performance.
And I used to stress about it and now I
feel like I can indulge in these great
foods and not have to
worry about my race way.
I find it comes naturally now I'm
without all the stress of counting,
I think it was actually counterproductive.
So I'm just hoping that uh,
these recipes can really enhance whatever
goals you have athletically or just
health wise.
A lot of people ask us, we're going to
have some questions, time for questions,
but I'll go ahead and ask the question
then. I know we're going to get asked. Um,
everyone asks us that every
stop, every city, well,
I don't run a hundred miles a week
and I eat these foods. And really, um,
this is if you're not 120,
so a lot of people are like,
Whoa, well I don't run that much.
So it is really applied to me. Can I
really eat that? And the answer is yes,
this is for anyone of any level,
whether you're a marathon is a 12 hour
day at Google or you're chasing after a
toddler is you're running.
My running is three to five miles and
often with a stroller and not every day.
And it really varies. And when
you eat this way, this is,
this is good food for anyone.
When you eat this way,
you're just so satisfied and so energized
that you're gonna want to get out
there and do these adventures,
um, at on the one hand.
And then just real food isn't real.
Real food doesn't cause weight gain.
It's all the sugars and processed foods.
So if you really made a commitment to
sourcing good ingredients and getting in
your kitchen and cooking, then
yes, you can eat this late too.
Okay.
So yeah, if anyone has questions,
we have time for answering.
So we have a mic set up right here
for questions. Please form a line,
ask your questions.
MMM.
Actually I have a couple of questions.
Um,
the most important question for me is
like how do you source them, you know,
what do you call it? Good food.
Like for example, um, beef. So, uh,
I've tried the different kinds
of beef before I owned a,
there's only one source would be
if I had that was really good.
Uh, but that's from Hawaii and
it's really hard to get to.
Yeah, you guys are really less
with access in Seattle state,
incredible ingredients.
So I would really highly recommend getting
to know your farmers that your local
farmer's market,
um,
and they find direct from a farmer is
going to give you the best source of the,
um, when you go to the grocery store,
you have the options of the organic,
some hiring versus stories like that with
Luke grocery stores will also have the
graph said options.
So I always choose the grass fed option,
organic labeling as a bit misleading
because it's gotten to be so mainstream
that now you have mass
produced organic foods.
So anytime that you can get your food
closer to the source and in Seattle and
have amazing access to local farmer's
markets, that's the best bet.
And you could make a commitment to
go to a farmer's market once a month,
but even if you don't have time
to go to the farmer's market,
a lot of farms will deliver direct.
So even where I live in bend,
Oregon,
there's a CSA which is a community
supported agriculture farm share and they
will deliver, I don't know if we
will have deliveries direct to here,
but in bed he could have um,
produce and meat delivered direct
to your office or into your home,
which is an awesome opportunity.
And a lot of food labels
are really like misleading.
You see like grass and
cage free and all of this.
But when you're buying
direct from a farmer,
you don't have to stress when you're
getting it from a small local farms there,
they're the ones who are committed to
taking care of their land because they
want to be able to pass their
park down in generations.
We have a great source that we
love is pine on ranch in bend,
Oregon, just outside of where I live.
And they have a website, um, hi.
Not Ranch and you can order on amazing
ice in and Yak and have it delivered.
Mail lit like ice axes.
Yeah. Yeah. My daughter loves Yak.
My two year old Pine Mountain
Mountain Ranch Moodle
most.
Okay.
Um, I don't want it to you.
Let's just get, we'll ask him,
but I do have another question. So you
mentioned the bar could meet the chicken.
So what does that mean?
I know
guys, you have the chicken. Um,
so when I buy chicken I buy a whole
chicken and I get it from a reputable a
farmer or reputable grocery
store. Um, even like whole foods,
you can buy the whole chicken
and use every part of it.
And that's the best way to eat
meat because you get to the chief.
The dark money is the thigh and the late.
Um,
but also I use every part of the
chicken so we don't eat a lot of me,
but we definitely have meat every
day and eat it as like as a side.
So we have a lot of vegetables and
the meat is a smaller side dish. Um,
and just it's, you use every part
of it. You can make bone broth,
which is incredibly mineral rich,
nourishing time,
which is great for fall flat fighting
inflammation and for recovery and are
getting,
we're getting into the flu season.
So we have a recipe in here for bumper
off and that you can make like a chicken
stew, which is full of ginger and garlic
is really good for boosting your news.
Listen.
Um, I also have a question
about the, um, I don't know.
I don't know what the fuck out
of people, but um, so there's me,
there's advantages, but we also eat
a lot of a flower and rice, you know,
how do you source had those kind of
things like that from Costco or from,
you know,
a whole foods or wet do just awesome
because we need to use a lot of them.
Like on regular basis.
My favorite source for whole
grains is Bob's red mill.
And you can find it at a lot of wills,
even like Safeway or mainstream purchase
where you can find Bob's red mill.
They're based in Oregon and they have,
um,
all kinds of whole grains like
Farro and Kheema. And you can get,
um,
like ground flowers too for making,
we have a lot of wholesome treats in our
book and they're made with whole grain
flours. Um, rice,
I would say we like to stick
to short grain brown rice.
Brown rice is more nutritious and make
sure arranges for the texture and you can
find that in the bulk section
at any health food store
concussion.
So I've been a question about, uh, during
and post workout nutrition. You know,
I find that it's really hard obviously
while you're running and then immediately
afterwards,
you know,
the last thing I want to do after a
long run is still in the kitchen for 20
minutes cooking something. Do you pre
mean just food or how do you handle that?
Yeah.
Um, concerning while you're
running. So do you like,
do you consume a sports drink or a joke?
I've been using the power bars.
Super happy with it, but yeah. Um,
we have some treats in here that are great
for like while you're running as well
as post run. Um, my favorite
that we have our opinion shoes,
which are just a natural, um, but they're
cooked a little bit new, the chewy.
So it's like, you know, you see
a lot of those sports gummies,
so replaces the synthetic kind of gummies
and this simple sugars that are not as
great for you.
We also have what we call Guinea up
energy bars and they're made of dates and
variety of dried fruit and
um, and that's in it. So,
um, gates and nuts are great
for light source to fuel you.
Um, when I'm competing I just drink
a sports drink. And so that's,
uh,
but that's necessary.
Like there's times and places where
you're drinking the sports stream.
Otherwise I'm thinking usually like a
coconut water most of the time or just
simple water. Um, but
I get you after Ryan,
the last thing you want to
do is get in the kitchen. Um,
so sometimes I'll try to like prepare a
little bit and maybe half my meal prior.
Um, but right after a run I usually
have, um, our beats movie sounds weird.
It's delicious.
And that really just get something in
immediately because you have kind of a
window to kind of refuel and
it'll make it feel a lot better.
And if you refuel right away,
you're going to be a little bit more
motivated to get in the kitchen.
So my goto though, once I
get in the kitchen are just
some veggies and scrambled.
The egg,
it's really simple.
Um, but yeah, at least you have more. Yes.
If you're not hungry Radtke
rounds you so thirsty as,
and he is a great solution and especially
you're putting other ingredients in
there besides fruits and
veggies to balance out all.
You don't want to just
have this big sugar rush.
So putting all in veteran there for the
good fat and whole milk yogurt has made
me like any good organic
whole milk yogurt. It that
into your smoothies is great.
Awesome.
Thank you.
Hmm.
Huh?
I'm a question you'll be always on carbs.
So on the one hand it's the fuel,
like we do carb loading before a marathon
and I probably during their training
and on the other hand there are a
lot of abuse against carbs like the,
I read the book from fuel method tongue.
I'm the big book of enduring sat book,
have some extreme views
but it does help a lot.
They also have the quick recipe there.
He wholly against human carbs and even
against carb loading before a marathon.
He also recommends things like a grass
fed grass fed beef from local farms.
So what's the Obo on light carbs?
If I were to just ask about the
women that I compete against,
men like in the Olympics were running
the marathon during this athletes,
none of them are not consuming
carbs. Everyone would be
like car. They need carbs.
You need like a gen to
doing endurance events.
So that may said it would not do the no
carbs, not really into any trend at all.
Like, we just think that what you eat on
a daily basis and weekly basis and then
you're training for example is what you
should be fueling basically before the
race. So I will add in a little bit
of extra cars the week of the race,
but I don't go hog while I don't go and
sit and have like a giant bowl of pasta
the night before. I think I would spend
half my racing the importer. Yawn.
You have to like everything in moderation.
Anything extreme is not what we're about.
Everything is all about moderation. Um,
so we find that it is important to do
the carpet loading but it's very small.
So like more more of my snacks,
snacks throughout the week
we'll be carbo oriented,
but otherwise they eat exactly the
way I would eat through my training.
Do I need to,
uh,
limit carb intake to
loose weight because okay.
No,
that his car,
there's a big difference in the change
process. Carbs and hopefully parts.
So you do want to avoid the process.
Carbs like the bread,
white flour and white sugar and breads
and all the packaged foods out there.
Made with really highly processed carbs
that have no nutrients but the carb,
carbohydrates fees and our books are all
are complex carbs like sweet potatoes
and whole grains and all these things
that are going to be balanced energy
versus these unhealthy spices.
Um,
not only because he's not brave
but also lead to weight gain.
But it is good to avoid
the processed carbs.
Okay.
I'm going gonna just,
I'll just full up little bit more on
that specific question again. Carbs.
So he wasn't doing his intellect so you
consume carbs but we'd like not white
carbs. So pastor the buckwheat
pasta and yes. Yeah, yeah.
[inaudible] it out.
Um,
so the night before I
run the Boston Marathon.
I mean loading up on this week that too,
cause no,
he's going to explain why it seems to,
it's a great source of a carbohydrate
as opposed to like we were talking about
this strip flowers that
really have I no nutrition.
So we pass it. It's kind of
misleading packaging. Um,
same with wheat bread.
If it says whole wheat Pasta,
whole wheat bread on the
outside of the package.
If you flip to the back and
look at the actual ingredients,
the first ingredient is just wheat flour.
It's not actually a whole wheat.
So when you're buying red
and one of the first grade,
it would be whole wheat flour and I'd
just be loud and there's a lot of other
things like that. This lean packaging.
Um, we eat pasta, we're not gluten free,
but um, but we don't eat
like a big map of the pasta.
Instead we will have a small serving of
pasta with a lot of sauces and salsas
pack with veggies and meat
and all the good stuff. Um,
and then others good
carbohydrates are runners is um,
grabbing rights or his favorite
is wild rice and we have a,
a wild rice salad in here.
That's amazing.
I'm on Fario or Kheema and there's
lots of other great sources. Um,
but we're not going to
say don't eat pasta.
Yeah, the one thing that's,
what about like, again,
we get some [inaudible]
assuming the no yogurt milk
Sherry there. Yes. Yes. The
dairy is pretty hard to digest.
A lot of renters are sensitive to
dairy and sensitive. They can live in.
A lot of runners suffer from GI
distress because when you're running,
your blood is flowing away from your
digestive system and going to your
hardworking muscles.
Um,
so dairy can be very hard to
digest because of how it's
processed in our country.
Um, it's very, it's homogenized
and ultra pasteurized.
So they're heating it to
these extreme temperatures.
It's killing off all the
good probiotics and enzymes,
which makes it really difficult to
break down the lactose in the dairy.
And so we have,
in our book,
we don't use cream or milk in seven we
use varies that are easier to digest,
like whole milk yogurt,
which have probiotics in it and aged
cheeses like Parmesan and they age the
cheese. It has, it has the enzymes
and it's a lot easier to digest.
You also love goat cheese and doesn't
have a lactose that's in Berryville a of
people have palms.
So shallow.
You don't drink coffee with milk?
Oh No, I do, but not a lot.
I usually I prefer actually almond milk.
What's the time?
Uh,
you mentioned that you used to count
your calories a lot and like you wouldn't
be satisfied with the food,
are happy with the food and the answer
is you change it. This diet, not diet,
weight off eating. Yeah. Uh, he helped a
lot and you don't change your diet much.
Can you elaborate more on like how much
you change your eating close to raise or
if you change at all?
Yeah,
so like at least helped me realize that
the way our culture and how you grew up,
who is in green to have
everything both that.
So like in my fridge it would be
low fat yogurt and um, I would have,
you know, fake butters price thinking
this was all healthy. Am I do here I was,
I was thinking I was doing myself that
I was doing a good job taking care of
myself. Um, but it always left me
hungry and not feeling satiated.
I always felt like I was constantly
hungry and just could never feel full.
And there was a reason why.
It's because I was eating all,
everything so low fat and a lot of low
fat foods. Just put mom in a lot of sugar.
So out of my body was just burning
it and just ripping through it.
So it was feeling hungry all the time,
which is not fun to run around hungry.
And I have a lot of training.
I run them close to, you know,
sometimes 20 miles a day and that
left me just not in a good place.
So I felt like, um, you know,
with counting calories and having to
eat all of these kind of landlord foods,
I just felt like unmotivated
and uninspired to eat and
uninspired to get in the
kitchen and cook and once at
least taught me how to integrate,
like making my own salad
dressings was really good oils.
I'm eating chicken the eyes and
said of all the white breasts, um,
having nice buttery sauces on my pasta.
I just started to feel
like it was more indulgent.
I was enjoying my food more and I just
felt like I didn't need to count calories.
So it's just my weight was
naturally finding a good
place and I didn't feel like
you have to stress about it anymore.
And she told me that she was like,
only numbers you should be concerned about
or what your watches reading and what
your splits are for your workouts.
How many miles are running a day.
Worried about those numbers.
Ben,
in the idea of counting
calories and plus on top of it,
I couldn't count calories because all the
foods I was eating more natural foods.
I don't know how many calories
are in each, you know,
I'm an apple unnecessarily.
Every Apple's different.
And when you're eating whole
foods, there's no need to
read the nutrition label.
So it just completely opened up.
Um,
my way of looking at food and
it's been like a huge relief.
And I have found that here at
age 35 and I feel rejuvenated.
And then he, my fourth Olympic team
and that's hard to do at my age.
Not many 35 year old Olympians.
And um,
I feel like it's because I've changed
my diet in way, well I should say diet,
my way of eating.
No, I have a follow up to that. So
sometimes when I'm in happy training,
I wake up hungry. Like in the
middle night, like four or three.
You have this kind of stuff
or do you change your diet?
When I used to,
I used to always have like a snack by my
bed is I would wake up and it'd be like,
oh my gosh, I'm so hungry.
I can't wait till breakfast.
I have to like promise snap right now.
So you said literally I'm food on my
nightstand because there's usually like a
packaged bar or something.
Um, you know, athletes,
it's a bars are always like
pushed at you all the time. Um,
so now I go to bed and I'm full throughout
the night and then I'm ready to eat
in the morning.
But I'm not like we've all the nights,
but the hunger pains are
what waking me up, which,
what happened a lot
when I'm cheating heart.
Yeah.
Before I ask my question can
invite you ladies to sit.
You've been standing where the rest of us.
Um,
so,
uh,
I was kinda curious cause there's a lot
of trends out there and one particular
one, I have a friend who really
got excited. Soylent. Uh,
what is your take on silent?
So lend,
it's uh, uh, nevermind.
I guess if it's a they da is that they're
sourcing a bunch of sugars and fats
from different places and then they put
them in a bottle or a powder. Right?
So it's supposed to be pre balanced,
all that stuff.
There's warranty eating.
Then just like the nutrients,
there's the act of eating
and sitting down to a meal.
Part of the community and the social
aspect of eating food and cooking wakes up
your digestive system.
There's so much more to you than just
like drinking down nutrients so that those
products scare me. They're also really
highly processed in a lab and they're not,
um, it's not real food. So
yeah, not crazy about that.
I never even heard of it.
Ask a non food question.
Just what a couple of questions to a
[inaudible] about running Moscow. Oh,
my first question was can you comment?
Like what is your opinion on the,
there is some amazing work
[inaudible] like what's your in?
Okay,
very.
It's like my boy, I came, you
actually even conceptualize,
so he's asked me about the
Olympics and then 10,000 meter,
which I am bronze medal from Beijing,
China,
and then 10,000 meters. And
um, but in Rio this summer, um,
there was a woman for Ethiopia who ran
the world record in the race and it was,
I couldn't believe my eyes watching her.
It's beyond my comprehension.
I'm Charlene isn't America.
Yeah. Um, and so she ran, um,
half of the race faster than I could run,
like,
so at five k or 5,000 meters,
she's ran her first 5,000,
hundred second 5,000 faster
than I've ever run one.
So I can't even conceptualize, um, it
was just an outstanding performance. Um,
unfortunately with athletics,
sometimes what seems
unbelievable is unbelievable. Um,
I don't know what to think
about it, um, just because, uh,
as maybe many of you read over the
summer and there was a lot of, um,
doping stories and, um, you know,
with Russia being extracted from the
Olympics and not allowed. So it's hard to,
it's just hard to know what
is real or not real. However,
I will say there's not many 10,000 meter
races and opportunities to run really
fast. So maybe, um, she
really just is that good,
but we'll find out. But she
resumed. It was so impressive.
Yes.
And then can we just talk a little bit,
what is next for you
next? Branding wise? Yes.
Um, well I'm taking a nice little
great, um, on this book tour.
It's fun to do something different.
I,
my lifestyle is very monastic.
When I'm training for a marathon,
it's three months of a lot of dedication.
It's run, eat, sleep, running,
sleep for p, it's very much the same
thing. It's what I call groundhog day.
If any of you seen that movie, that's my
life. When I'm training for a marathon,
it's not very eventful.
Uh,
so it's fun for me to do other
activities and engage with people.
I feel like when I come
out of marathon training,
I'm in like shock and I don't know
how to even communicate. It's like,
do I even know English? Like
it's a, it's a little scary.
So it's fine to just be inspired by my
running community and the cooking world.
Uh, it, it motivates me to get back
to my training by taking a break.
And so probably come December and January
I'll be back at the grind of running a
sleep and I have aspirations.
My,
my love affair with running is a in
Boston. I love the Boston Marathon.
I grew up there,
so I may show up in Boston next April.
That may be part of my plan. Um,
but beyond that, I don't know.
I'm taking one race at a time. Um, a
lot athletes thinking four year chunks,
but right now I'm just going to go
one flight month was that,
so I want to ask about morning rounds
and you may have to luxury not to have to
deal with this,
but,
but how do you deal when you're trying
to get a long run it in the morning,
you know,
do you wake up at 4:00 AM to eat and
then go back to sleep for a few hours or
um, if I'm just doing chaining.
Yeah, yeah, exactly. Um, yeah.
So I,
I like to eat about 90 minutes
prior to the start over run.
Um,
and I know that,
that maybe this is like a luxury
for me because that's my job. Uh,
but so if like for example,
if you were wanting to start your run,
what at like 5:00 AM you're saying and
you want it to get in before work or,
or, yeah. Or You'd have family or
three hours at like,
you know, 7:00 AM 609.
I mean, the key is the key in the morning,
and this is maybe a little
bit too much information,
is to get up and get it moving so that
you're not gonna have any GI issues out
on the trail. How did it make a pit stop?
So that's usually what most mentors are.
Like, let's get up like an hour
before, so I get some food in,
make sure that you've made your bathroom
stop and you can head out on the trail
on the road and be good to go.
Um,
so I usually get up about
like an hour before,
but sometimes that's hard to do
if it's dark and cold. And, um,
but usually on the ride to like we're
drive or if I'm going to go run to drive,
um,
or run dry it to go run,
I will take like a smoothie or
one of our superhero muffins and
that kind of right before I get out there.
So yeah,
you don't have time for breakfast.
And I,
I run an early and before my husband
leaves for work in before I start,
we're being in. Um, so I don't,
at that hour at 6:00 AM I'm not hungry,
so I'll just get up and have some
coconut water mixed with water,
diluted with water and
either coffee or tea.
And I'm like a couple of days
just frozen quick energy.
But a three hour run is different.
Like I know less than that. So, um,
you definitely get some
good quick glucose,
right?
That's the end of our talk.
We're going to have a book signing
over at that table over there.
There's still some books available for
purchase over here and everybody please
give a warm thank you to Shane and Elise.